[Music]
what's up guys rip and mark man here at
the playstation competition center to
bring you some tips on tekken 7.
today we're going to talk about one of
the most important aspects of attacking
in tekken attack heights
virtually all attacks in tekken fall
under three main heights high attacks
mid attacks and low attacks if you want
to check out which height a certain
attack is
jump into training mode and turn on hit
properties in the display settings
section the differences are not just
cosmetic
each attack serves a specific purpose in
your offensive arsenal
to understand how to use these attacks
we must first learn how blocking works
in tekken 7.
characters can be standing up or
crouching when standing up you will
block both high and mid attacks but low
attacks will hit you
when crouching you will block low
attacks but mid-attack will hit you and
high attacks will just miss over your
head entirely
so the first obvious question is if high
attacks either get blocked or missed
entirely why use them at all
why not just use only mids or lows which
lead to damage if the defender blocks
incorrectly
well let's first talk about mid attacks
many powerful fast combo starters like
uppercuts and hopkicks are mid attacks
so if you crouch block often you risk
getting hit by these launchers and
losing a lot of health very quickly
also the faster low attacks in tekken 7
often do very small amounts of damage
and don't lead to combos
the stronger low attacks tend to be
slower and with some practice you will
learn to react and block them in time
so this means in tekken 7 it's generally
a better idea to block standing more
often than crouching
and that's what makes high attacks very
practical even though they whiff against
crouching opponents
most players will prefer to stand and
avoid those dangerous mid attacks
many useful moves in tekken 7 are high
attacks these useful high attacks often
let you continue your momentum
even if your opponent has blocked them
so they are great for maintaining your
offense
and if your opponent notices this and
starts to crouch more bring out your
most dangerous mid attack to show them
why they shouldn't duck
of course if you're standing the entire
time your opponent may attack you with a
lot of small damage but annoying low
attack
and over time you're gonna lose quite a
bit of light so how do you handle those
two
all those in tekken 7 come with the
universal weakness every character in
the game can carry low attack by tapping
and holding the down forward direction
on the controller
if the enemy attack is low in doing this
you automatically knock them down
and can land a follow-up combo so now
you're on the offense instead
so if an opponent attacks too often with
loads low pairing is a great way to turn
the tide
as you can see there's a nice balance
between the different attack heights the
high the mid and the low
by standing there you'll be able to
block very damaging and dangerous mid
attacks but you're also forced to block
these high attacks and you might need
some low attacks
alternatively if you're ducking you put
yourself at a huge risk and you might
eat a mid-launcher
right and even if you just learn one or
two attacks from each of these hit
ranges you know it's really enough to
keep your opponent guessing
that's it for this episode this tutorial
is made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can check out compete.playstation to
watch
learn and compete subscribe to the bne
esports channel for more tutorials
and tekken 7 content